así es que estás en la clase de
matemáticas y tu maestro está hable y
hable acerca de un artículo decía
alfombra se debería enseñar en la
escuela o no y ni siquiera se da cuenta
de que lo que está enseñando no es
álgebra que podría haber sido muy
interesante no cómo manipular símbolos
en ciertos casos especiales de álgebra
elemental que no está el jabra entonces
en lugar de aprender sistemas auto
consistentes y pensamiento lógico pasas
toda la semana memorizando cómo graficar
parábolas ninguna noticia nueva a nadie
le interesan las palabras por lo que la
mitad de la clase está jugando angry
birds a escondidas pero no tienes un
smartphone y tienes que recurrir a una
forma más noble y fuera de moda para
combatir el aburrimiento
así es que empiezas a dibujar y has
inventado tu propio juego que conecta
puntos que tiene todo el sentido del
mundo a diferencia de las materias en su
historial académico en lugar de conectar
los puntos más cercanos para encontrar
la misteriosa figura oculta sigue es un
método preciso que se salta a cierta
cantidad de puntos y los conectas de
esta forma hace tiempo caracteriza este
cómo se vería si tus puntos estaban
acomodados en un círculo digamos 11
puntos y conecta el punto 1 al punto 4 y
sigue con los demás así obtienes esas
estrellas
y puede dibujar las líneas en el orden
de los puntos o puede seguir la línea y
tal vez llegues a todos los puntos
aunque tal vez no dependiendo de cuántos
puntos hay en tu círculo y cuántos te
saltas t pero también hay otras formas
los círculos se llevan muy bien con las
ondas senoidal es y las ondas senoidal
es se llevan muy bien con las ondas
cuadradas y tenemos que admitirlo eso se
ve muy padre de hecho dos simples líneas
rectas de puntos cuando conectas los
puntos de una línea con la otra en orden
de alguna forma producen está padrísima
curva con mucho movimiento y otro alumno
le está preguntando al profesor si
alguna vez va a necesitar saber cómo se
grafica en las parábolas y además está
escondiendo bajo el escritorio su juego
favorito que principalmente dibuja
parábolas diseñado por una empresa
multimillonaria si tu profesor pensar en
ello seguramente pensaría que dispararle
pájaros a cosas es una buena razón para
interesarnos en las parábolas porque
pues ha concluido que la educación se
trata de dinero y prestigio y no de
convertirse en un mejor ser humano capaz
de hacer grandes cosas tú mismo no has
hecho nada grandioso todavía pero te
imaginas que el camino para tu futura
genialidad lo encontrarás buscando
formas de conectar puntos más padres
muchísimo antes que memorizando como
gráfica una parábola o disparando
pájaros y ahí es donde empiezas a
preocuparte qué tal que esta curva
padrísima que dibujas te aproxima una
parábola como cualquier maestro no se da
cuenta de que todo el mundo tiene su
celular debajo de la mesa pero le paga
un poco y trabaja mucho y su mundo gira
alrededor de un proceso de negación
así es que pastor examen y da clases en
secundaria si prestas alumnos que no son
engañados por su falso entusiasmo y sus
falsas matemáticas y él pretende que
enseña álgebra y los alumnos pretenden
que aprenden álgebra y todos demás
involucrados en el sistema están
demasiado interesados en pretender que
le creen a los dos tú crees que tal vez
es una hipérbola que es similar a una
parábola por el hecho de que ambas son
secciones de una crónica una hipérbola
es un lindo corte vertical de un cono un
cono siendo como un remolino de líneas
girando alrededor de círculos y es por
eso que un cono es como dos conos de
helado radiando en ambas direcciones la
preciosa y pero la directa no ambas
partes dos curvas perfectas pareciendo
disco nexos pero compartiendo la misma
cónica de origen y bueno la aburrida
vieja parábola es una rebanada con un
ángulo escogido específicamente
no tocar la parte de arriba del cono y
para no atravesar completamente de la
parte de abajo como lo haría una elipse
y es un caso muy especial y específico
de las secciones cónicas que todas las
parábolas son exactamente iguales solo
más grandes chicas o trasladadas y
rotadas de hecho tu mente podría darte
parábolas ya dibujadas y ponerte a
dibujar los planos cartesiano si las
coordenadas encima de ellas en lugar de
dibujar parábolas sobre el plano
cartesiano y es estúpido y las odia si
no quieres aprender a graficar las
incluso cuando eso signifique no hacer
un juego de 10 millones de pesos que
disparen pájaros mientras tanto
cualquier persona que aprenda a pensar
matemáticamente puede aprender después a
graficar una parábola o cualquier cosa
que necesiten como cinco minutos pero
enseñar a pensar es un proceso
individual que le da poder y
responsabilidad a los individuos
mientras que enseña en qué pensar se
puede hacer con una lista puntos extras
palomitas y estrellitas y nuestra
cultura nos obliga a subir la escalera
paso por paso aplacados en esa cómoda
estructura llena de tautología y con
expectativas claras álgebra se ha
convertido una materia a la que hay que
ponerle palomita y yo
en lo alto de una torre el desagradable
destino al que ha sido condenada pero
que no te interesa las palomitas a ti te
interesan los puntos y las líneas que
los conectan o tal vez podrías
conectarlos con semicírculos para poder
visualizarlos bien porque las líneas
quedarían unas encima de otras o podrías
decir que un punto es el centro y que el
otro define el radio y dibujar un
círculo completo podrías poner nuevas
reglas cada punto es el centro de un
círculo con su vecino siendo el radio o
decides que un punto base el centro de
todos los círculos y todos demás definen
los radios pero entonces obtienes por
círculos concéntricos que supongo que
era algo obvio desde el principio pero
qué pasa si lo hacemos al revés si
hacemos que un punto siempre esté en el
círculo y el resto de los puntos sean
los centros así se ven más prometedor no
entonces tratas de poner todos los
puntos de un círculo y decides usarlos
como centros de un círculo y escoges un
solo punto que pase por todos los
círculos y obtienes de esta forma
padrísima que se ve como un corazón
así es que llamémosle no sé un cardio y
de que resulte hacer la misma curva que
obtienes cuando líneas rectas como rayos
de luz se reflejan en un círculo el
mismo corazón de luz solar innata
o tal vez en lugar de centros de
círculos podrías tener todos los puntos
en la curva del círculo lo que significa
que necesitas tres puntos para poder
definir el círculo tal vez un punto y
sus dos vecinos más cercanos para
empezar y por supuesto cualquier
colección de círculos se puede colorear
con dos colores así es que puedes
contrastar con colores oscuros o colores
clásicos o tal vez puedes poner puntos
al azar y poner todos círculos posibles
aunque estos serían demasiados círculos
y decides poner nada más los que quieres
y después en contra de tu voluntad te
empiezas a preguntar cuántos puntos son
necesarios para definir la aburridísima
para volar porque todas las parábolas se
parecen mucho a los círculos
ambos son elipses extremas un círculo es
tomar un foco de la elipse y poner el
otro foco distancia cero y la parábola
es como una elipse cuando el foco está a
una distancia infinita y es por eso que
todos mienten cuando dicen que aventar
pelotas o disparar pájaros se trata de
puras parábolas en realidad se trata de
elipse porque la tierra es una esfera y
de hecho la gravedad no va directamente
hacia abajo el otro foco de la
trayectoria elíptica de tu proyectil de
elección se encuentra muy lejos pero muy
lejos siempre es mucho
más cerca que una distancia infinita así
es que no nos engañemos no todo lo que
parece parabólico es una parábola seguro
si conectas dos puntos por una cuerda se
ve parabólico al igual que la estructura
de los arcos pero en realidad son arcos
catenarias y tal vez no lo puedes notar
a simple vista pero si eres un
arquitecto más te vale saber cuál es la
diferencia las catenarias están muy
relacionadas con las palabras les
obtienes al hacer rodar una parábola y
marcando la trayectoria del foco lo cual
las hace un pariente cercano de la
elipse e incluso la iv pero la es como
una elipse que quedó volteada o cuyo
foco se fue hasta el infinito y regreso
del otro lado y por supuesto las elipses
parábolas hipérbola son todas las
secciones cónicas lo cual significa que
todas provienen de una línea crecido
muchísimo en forma circular y una línea
es lo que sucede cuando se conectan dos
puntos o tal vez lo que sucede cuando tu
círculo es tan grande que como la elipse
extrema que se convierte en una parábola
el círculo extremo se rompe en el
infinito y se convierte en una línea
antes de volverse más grande que
infinitamente grande lo cual lo lleva
del otro lado es este el círculo
infinito la línea que queda en medio o
tal
es lo que sucede cuando ruedas un
círculo y te picas en la trayectoria del
foco o más bien de los dos focos que
están a distancia cero el uno del otro y
eso te hace preguntarte qué pasa cuando
ruedas una elipse y sigues los focos de
hecho hay un montón de formas geniales
que puedes obtener al rodar otras formas
por ejemplo si ruedas un círculo
alrededor de otro círculo lo que
obtienes es otro círculo pero si sigues
la trayectoria de un punto en la
circunferencia lo que obtienes es
nuestro increíble amigo cara de hoy de
otra vez que ahora está relacionado con
los círculos en tres formas es un primo
directo de la elipse y ahora también es
un primo segundo de la elipse infinito o
sea de la parábola y no sólo eso si
tomas una parábola y lo inviertes con
respecto al círculo unitario invirtiendo
de adentro hacia fuera un medio se
convierte en 21 entre 100 se convierte
en 100 el 1 se queda como 1 el infinito
se convierte en 0 y obtienes otra vez el
cardio y de así es que el cardio es la
anti parábola lo cual está súper bien
porque las palabras te ponen triste pero
tú amas a los cardio y des y por
supuesto que quieres conectados puntos
en lugar de dibujar la línea pues doblar
la hoja ese es el asunto acerca de
conectar los puntos y la vida puede ser
que te den explícitamente todos
a seguir y puedes elegir el paso que sea
más cercano y más sencillo y estar
seguro de lo que vas a obtener todo el
tiempo hacerlo es muy cómodo y seguro lo
puedes intentar nuevas formas de
conectar los puntos y no sabrás lo que
va a obtener tal vez sea algo increíble
tal vez parecerá un error y cuando sea
un fracaso será tu culpa y no puede
echarle la culpa a nadie más
no puedes echarle la culpa a las
matemáticas ni el sistema ni a las
listas con palomitas pero yo sí voy a
cometer errores preferiría que fueran
los míos
esta es una traducción de un vídeo hecho
por by heart y muy probablemente puedes
encontrar la liga al vídeo original en
la descripción de este vídeo búscalo
porque está buenísimo